je fais le tirage au sort dimanche soir
salut pour ce nouveau master class' je vais vous parler d'une technique pour retenir les prénoms des personnes
un test a été réalisé
lorsque 2 personnes se rencontrent
on donnait des informations et on a regardé ce qui était le mieux retenu
69% des participants ont retenus le métier
68% des participants ont retenus les loisirs de la personne
69 et 68 ça fait pas 100% c'est normal à chaque fois on s’intéressait qu'à un sujet
et on vérifiait le nombre de personnes qui avaient retenus ce sujet là
62% des participants avaient retenus la ville dont venait la personne
31% avaient retenus le prénom
et 30% le nom de famille
et ça me conforte dans les discussions que j'ai avec les spectateurs à la fin des spectacles
c'est quand même la chose qui revient le plus à mes oreilles quand on parle de mémoire
le "raah moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à retenir le visage et le prénom des gens"
heureusement il y a des techniques pour savoir faire ça et je vais vous les apprendre dans ce master class'
tout d'abord quand on vous présente quelqu'un  il faut accorder un vrai temps de concentration
comme quand on veut apprendre quelque chose
malheureusement souvent quand on demande le prénom de quelqu'un on l'écoute que d'une oreille
on le classe en mémoire immédiate c'est juste pour le répéter derrière et on passe à autre chose
on accorde pas notre attention pleinement à ce sujet là
quand on vous présente quelqu'un il faut vous recentrer quelques secondes oublier un peu se qu'il se passe, se focaliser sur la personne
en se disant "ok j'ai envie de la rencontrer quel est votre prénom" et mettre toute son attention sur ce moment
une fois que la personne dit son prénom vous devez le répéter vous même à voix haute
ça va l'inscrire un petit peut plus longtemps dans votre mémoire et surtout  vous allez vous entendre vous même le prononcer
donc vous allez travailler également votre mémoire auditive
ce qui donnerait:
"_bonjour comment vous vous appelez
_team Mentalo ? enchanté team Mentalo moi c'est Fabien"
oui parce que...oui je vous ai donné un prénom collectif aujourd'hui
ensuite immédiatement imaginez sur le front de la personne son prénom
soit tatoué
soit écris en gros avec un feutre
le président Roosevelt faisait ça, lui il imaginait un coup de tampon encreur
donc comme écrit avec un tampon
visualisez ça, essayez juste d'imaginer son prénom écrit, tatoué ou dessiné sur son front
pas forcément en noir d'ailleurs ça peut être dans votre couleur préférée ou dans la couleur préférée de la personne
vous pouvez vous amuser avec cette petite visualisation qui prend quelques secondes à peine
durant tout ce processus ne lachez pas du regard la personne vous pouvez continuer de parler avec elle
essayer de replacer le prénom aussi souvent que vous le pouvez
si par exemple c'est au cours d'une soirée et que la personne s'en va faire autre chose, vous la recroisez dans la soirée, tout de suite replacez le prénom
le fait de le répéter ça va commencer à le caler dans une mémoire un petit peu plus à long terme
et j'ai un tips, une astuce qui fonctionne très bien pour associer le visage en même temps au prénom
c'est de trouver soit un moyen mémo-technique
si on me présente quelqu'un qui s’appelle Sébastien je vais l'imaginer dans le générique de Belle et Sébastien avec le chien à côté de lui ect.
si on me présente quelqu'un qui s’appelle Jean-Paul je vais l'imaginer en blanc en pape dans une papomobile en train de faire bonjour
et si j'ai pas forcément une mémo-technique immédiate qui me viens je prends soit un acteur célèbre  soit quelqu'un que je connais
si je rencontre quelqu'un qui s'appelle Jean, je vais l'imaginer avec Jean Dujardin, les 2 l'un à côté de l'autre comme ça
comme si il était juste à coté de lui et qu'ils se tenaient limite par l'épaule
et intérieurement je me dirais "Jean comme Jean"
ça aussi ça prend que quelques secondes et ça permet de fixer beaucoup mieux la formation dans le temps
si vous prenez le temps de faire ça correctement et systématiquement la prochaine fois que vous allez recroiser la personne vous allez vous souvenir de son prénom
et si vous ne l'avez pas retenu il y a la très bonne méthode de Reagan
j'avais lu dans une biographie que Jacques Chirac utilisait également cette méthode
c'est une méthode digne d'un petit mentaliste à embrouille
Tout d'abord, Reagan montrait qu'il se souvenait qui était la personne.
Donc, il lui parlait de la ville où ils s'étaient rencontrés, ou de la ville où habitait la personne,
ou du métier de la personne, ou des hobbies de la personne
comme on l'a vu dans le test en début de vidéo.
C'est les informations qu'on retient le mieux.
En clair, il envoyait le message qu'il se souvenait qui était la personne
sans avoir besoin de re-prononcer le prénom.
Et un peu plus loin dans la conversation, il disait cette phrase magique :
"Heu... Par contre... Ça m'échappe. Rappelez-moi comment vous vous appelez déjà ?"
Si la personne disait son prénom, alors Reagan enchaînait en disant :
"Nan, mais, votre prénom, évidemment, je ne l'ai pas oublié.
C'est votre nom de famille qui m'échappe."
Et  vous l'avez compris, si la personne disait son nom de famille, il disait :
"Oui, je me souvenais de votre nom de famille, par contre, c'est sur votre prénom que j'ai un léger doute."
C'était une magnifique pirouette qu'on peut utiliser qu'une seule fois par personne.
C'est à utiliser vraiment avec modération, mais ça fonctionne.
J'espère que grâce à cette vidéo, vous allez mieux retenir les prénoms à partir d'aujourd'hui.
Faîtes-le, c'est très efficace, c'est très simple à mettre en place.
Y a pas besoin d'entrainement, il y a juste besoin de penser à le faire.
En clair, si vous le voulez, vous allez y arriver.
Si vous avez trouvé que cette vidéo vous serait d'une quelconque utilité,
vous pouvez me le faire savoir en oubliant pas de laisser un...
Comment il s'appelle déjà ?
Pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo puisque je lis tous vos commentaires, vraiment, chaque jour.
J'aime bien faire ça.
Et surtout pensez à vous abonner avant de partir,
puisque MENTALVLOG, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Il y a le calendrier de la chaîne dans le descriptif.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 11h, ciao !